All right, we have two different type of ad accounts within Google, and those two are
your just regular standard Google Ad account, Google Adwords account, and your what they
call MCC, and I believe that stands for My Client Center.
I could be wrong, and I don't care, okay, but I prefer to use the MCC.
I'm going to talk about both really quick.
The regular standard one, if you've never set up ads, you're going to be by default
be pushed over to that one, and what that is is basically you can set up one account,
and you can set up multiple campaigns underneath that one account.
The reason I like the MCC account is, well, I plan on doing this for real.
I plan on doing this big time, number one, but number two, it's just like an organizational
thing, so what I like to personally do is I like for every single project, I like to
have a new account and a new campaign.
It's just really nice, let's just say I'm doing Minneapolis Concrete, then I'm going
to create a new account.
I'm going to show you guys all this.
I'm going to create a Minneapolis Concrete account, and then I'm going to be able to
create a campaign within that one that's Minneapolis Concrete, and it's the campaign.
It's just a nice organizational tool so that I don't have to go in, it's one account, it's
just this smorgasbord of stuff.
However, I would prefer you to go fast, so if you're somebody that's never set up ads,
I would prefer you to just, whatever pops up when you go to Google, just set one up,
get them running, and we can go in later and switch the MCC account.
I don't want you slowing down.
That's the biggest thing.
I don't want you slowing down for anything.
Now, really, really quick, because I'm going to share my screen in just a moment.
In version 1.0, I use a regular Google Ad account, so for this training, I'm going to
use an MCC account.
If you're somebody that's new and like, oh my gosh, what does it look like if it's regular?
Just go and look at version 1.0.
I'm going to leave that in the Facebook group.
Go to the module 3, the digital steroids, and you'll see an example of setting it up
with just a regular Google Ad account that comes as default.
I want to show you an MCC account to be fair to those that have MCC accounts.
Lastly, if you have a regular account or you set up a regular account, you just need to
get in touch with Google.
I know they're a pain in the butt to reach, but to my knowledge, that's the easiest way
is you're going to find a number.
I'm going to see if I can find a number, put it in the description of a quick way to reach
It's always changing.
Plus, we're blaming it on COVID, and I honestly don't know.
It's always adjusting.
Get a hold of them and tell them you want to switch to an MCC account, and they'll do
it for you.
Okay?
I'm going to share my screen now.
All right.
Guys, quickest, easiest way, go to Google, and you're going to be blown away.
Type in Google AdWords.
Google AdWords.
Really, really simple.
Okay?
First thing that comes up is going to be the ad.
You can either click on that one if you want to charge Google.
They probably don't charge themselves.
I'm going to click on it.
If they charge themselves, they're idiots.
Okay?
Now, what you're going to do is you're going to sign in.
Now, you can do this however you want.
I would use some kind of company email or something that is going to be more broad rather
than just setting this up under your bentonvilleconcrete at gmail.com.
That's just my recommendation, but don't overthink this.
It doesn't matter.
I do want you to notice, though, it is going to ask you to sign in, and in some cases it
may just sign you in automatically based on the email you already logged into.
Guys, if you're not using Chrome for whatever number of time, go switch to Chrome.
Just trust me.
Okay?
All right, so I'm going to sign in.
All right, so guys, what you're seeing here is my Google Ad account.
This is my MCC account.
It's going to look a little bit different than some of yours are going to look.
If you guys do not have an MCC account, it's okay.
One thing I want to point out, if I haven't shown you already, I have run $1.2 million
of my own money.
I don't have any partners.
I don't have any of that.
This is my own hard-earned money.
I know what to not do and teach you what not to do because I have spent this.
Notice how I didn't say, I'll teach you what to do, because I feel like sometimes I learn
by learning what not to do, but I have spent a good chunk of change learning what I'm about
to show you.
Okay?
First thing I'm going to teach you to do is just to set up a new account.
Very, very simple.
Again, we're talking about inside of an MCC account, so if you have your own, you have
a different regular Google, if yours looks different than this, it's okay.
We just need to get an account set up.
Okay?
Really, really simple.
If you do have an MCC account, just click on, you guessed it, accounts, and then you
see this plus sign.
What would you think you would get?
If I were to hold a gun to your head, you'd probably be like, yeah, I probably want to
hit the plus.
Push the plus button.
Okay?
Then it's going to say, create new manager account, nope, create new account.
I don't want a new manager account.
That's the MCC account.
I just want a new account.
Okay?
Set one up for the project that we are currently doing with this example.
So, next thing that you're going to do is you're just going to put in a little bit of
information.
Okay?
So, on the account name, I just like to keep it really clean, and I like to put Queen Creek
Concrete.
Go figure.
Okay?
All right.
Type.
Now, this is where you need to pay attention.
Okay?
I'm going to have you do the smart campaign type, okay?
Trust me on this.
I know there's some of you guys that have been in the game forever, and you're like,
oh, I'm not going to do that because blah, blah, blah.
If you guys already know Google Ads like the back of your hand, then be my guest, but
if you've never run Google Ads, trust me, I understand if you look online, it's going
to charge you a little bit more money, but guess what it does?
It allows you to go fast, and money loves speed.
Okay?
So, you're not going to choose Google Ad account.
You're going to choose smart campaign account.
Boom.
Okay?
Select your country.
I don't care what country you're in.
I'm in the U.S., obviously.
Select your time zone.
Okay?
Honestly, I don't know if the way to do it is to select the time zone of the project,
whatever.
Typically, with this, what I understand is if you're going to do it by certain times,
and we're not going to mess that, so it doesn't matter.
I will probably do it as Phoenix time just for the heck of it.
Okay?
Select your currency, and then we're not going to invite any users, so just save and continue.
Now, it says you're about blah, blah, blah, okay.
You're making important changes to your account.
Keep your data safe.
Please confirm it's really okay.
It's going to confirm.
Okay.
So, now my account is set up, and I have so many, I like to just filter this and go name,
and I'm going to do Queen Creek, and here we are, ready, set, go.
So, guys, we've now successfully set up an account within our MCC My Client Center account.
If you are just using regular, like it's your first time logging in on that email, it's
probably already going to have an account set up.
If not, just push new account.
It's very, very easy to do.
Again, if you do not have an MCC, it's okay, and on version 1.0, I use a regular account,
so don't overthink it.
Don't stress it.
We are going to go and set up a campaign.